>> Tycely Williams:
Good afternoon.
It's wonderful seeing so many
book lovers in the house.
I'm really excited to
introduce an American treasure
who is going to keep a
wonderful conversation going.
Before we start, I'd
like to introduce myself.
I'm Tycely Williams,
the president
of the Junior League
of Washington.
We represent the
volunteer force,
that over the last 16 years
has helped the book festival
with book lines.
So, we are delighted
to be with you today.
I'd also like to thank the
Library of Congress for all
of their works as well as the
National Endowment for the Arts
for sponsoring our
time together.
I'd like to introduce
James McBride
who is a beloved American
writer and musician.
Many of you know
him as the recipient
of the 2013 National
Book Award for Fiction
for his novel "The
Good Lord Bird".
He is currently a
distinguished, yes, snap, snap.
[ Applause ]
He's currently a distinguished
writer in residence
at New York University.
He's a graduate of
Oberlin College, father --
yay, Oberlin in the
house, all right --
and father to three children.
Let's warmly welcome
our distinguished artist
for the time being.
Mr. McBride, we'd love to hear
more about "Five-Carat Soul"
and all that you've got.
And, as he's coming, he
will speak for 25 minutes,
and we will open it up to Q
and A for the remaining 20.
Enjoy. Thanks.
>> James McBride: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
You like me.
You really like me.
Thank you so much.
It's so nice to see
so many white --
I mean, I nice people
here today.
I really feel touched
and honored.
You know, I forgot
I was chewing gum.
You know, my mother told
me when I was little
that if you chew gum and swallow
it, your rear end will close up.
So, I've always been
cognizant, never --
you know, my brother said, "What
happens when you blow a bubble?"
That's too much information.
Anyway, I want to talk
today about my latest book,
and I know, like, you know,
when you go see someone talk,
you know, like, Willie Nelson
used to say, "If they ask me
to sing that song, "To All
the Girls I've Loved Before",
I'm going to kill somebody."
But, that's what they
wanted to hear him sing.
So, I know a lot of you want
to hear me talk about "Color
of Water" and Good Lord
Bird which I'll do,
after I finish hawking
this first,
but I won't shamelessly hawk it.
I'll just give you a
brief synopsis of it
and then share some
ideas with you about some
of the other books,
the other two books
that you might be interested
in, and then I'll be happy
to entertain any questions that
you might have or conversation
that you want to offer.
I'm delighted to see so many
of you here, and I'm cognizant
that this is the year
that Barbara Bush died,
and Barbara Bush and
Laura Bush have a lot
to do with why we're here.
They were big book lovers
-- and Michelle Obama --
they were huge book lovers,
but I know Laura Bush was really
a big reason why the National
Book Festival became what it is.
[ Applause ]
And, it, you know, it
doesn't take a lot to make --
to acknowledge someone,
just to say thank you
or to say they did
something good.
It really doesn't take
a whole lot to do that.
All you have to do is say
it and feel it and that's --
and you feel better, you know?
So, we buried Aretha
Franklin yesterday I guess
and Senator McCain today or
tomorrow, whenever that happens,
and we're a little bit
smaller because of it,
but we're a lot larger
because of what they are
and what they'll always be and
always represent, and that's--
[ Applause ]
I feel like I'm talking
to congress.
I'm like okay no.
Applause [inaudible] got
to shake everyone hand.
All right, so my latest book
is called Five-Carat Soul.
It's a book of short
stories and these --
some of these stories
happened long ago.
Some of them I wrote
when I was in my 20s,
and some of them
I wrote recently.
The most pertinent one to where
we are is a story called "Mr. P
and the Wind", and I wrote
this when I was a reporter
at the Washington Post.
I worked in the style section
here at the Post and that's
when Ben Bradlee
ran the newspaper,
and so I had the
pleasure of working
with some really
talented people.
By the way, I'm very proud
of what the Post has become
in the last three or four years.
It's really, really gotten, just
become a fantastic organization.
Plus it wasn't any
good when I was there,
but that's not the point.
No, it was always
a high standard
of journalistic excellence
but now even greater.
It's even more important that
you subscribe to the paper.
And, if you have to decide
between buying one of my books
and subscribing to the paper,
decide between another book
and just make sure --
all right, so I was --
when I was here in Washington,
DC, my brother's sons were
like nine and eight,
nine or something
like that respectively, and I
took them to the national zoo.
They wanted to see some animals.
So, we went to the national
zoo here, in Washington DC,
and I saw, that was the
last zoo I ever visited,
because it was just,
really, just painful
to see these magnificent
creatures --
I don't need to tell
you the rest.
It just was -- I didn't like it.
So, I wrote a short
story about it.
It became a novella, and I wrote
the whole thing when I was here
in Washington, DC, and I'll
read you the beginning of it,
and it's called Mr.
P and the Wind.
And, essentially, this is a
story about a lion who lives
in a zoo in Washington, DC, in
a world where animals can talk
to each other through the mind.
And, so this is how
the story begins.
I am a lion.
I live in a zoo, but I was once
a free lion and never forgot it.
Many years ago, before I
was captured and brung here,
I knowed a lion who ate a man.
His name was Box.
I don't know how Box
came to that name,
for violence got their own
names for their own purpose,
and that name was
a puzzlement to me.
Box is a human name, you see,
and it stands the reason maybe
a human gived him that name.
However it happened or whether
Box got a reason for telling it
or not telling it, it
ain't my business to know,
for most lions know that
man things often ain't got
no purpose.
And, no creature of the
jungle is going to sniff
around something that
ain't purposeful,
especially something
big as a name,
for lions got their own names
that's particular to them,
like Monkey Tricked Him or His
Wife Don't Visit or Orange Head
or Feet Smell Funny
or Don't Trust Her
because She's a Sun
or names like that.
For example, humans call me Hal,
but my real name is
Get Along Go Along.
I never knew Box's
real name, by the way.
I was never stupid enough
to ask about it neither,
for Box was what you call, a
plain old dry long soul lion.
He was a hard lion,
set in his ways.
He didn't take no
shit off nobody.
Now, Box was hard
set in his ways.
He couldn't adjust to nothing.
He didn't like fancy things,
no spring box rhinos, ostrich,
monkey, and all that
kind of jazz for him.
Just straight out bloods and
guts, zebra, snake, snake,
zebra, whatever he could get.
He was, what you
call, old country.
He didn't slaughter a lot,
but what he did slaughter,
he did eat.
Most of what he ate
was bigger creatures,
so the smallest scarcer
ones could grow big enough
for bigger eating later.
He didn't waste nothing,
including time.
So, when he see me walk
around one day when I was
but a little cub, he
said, "Sit here a minute.
I got something to tell
you," I sat down to listen,
for Box wasn't nobody to ignore.
Now, I've heard many
of story told to me
when I was a cub running free
back yonder in the plains
of Africa, and a bunch
of them stories was lies,
for animals ain't no
different than man that way.
The story starts out one day,
and five days later it grows
tree branches and leaves.
And, before you know it it's the
size of a mountain with caves
and rocks and you can't
see the top or the bottom
of the thing while
standing on top of it.
But, Box told me this story his
self, and Box wasn't the type
to lie and this is
what Box told me.
He was coming through
the jungle one day
and a hunter surprised
him, got the drop on him.
Box walked right past
him, never smelled him
or sensed him, nothing.
The man jumped out of a bush
from behind Box holding a spear
with dead lion scent
all over it.
He had Box dead to rights.
He had old Box cold.
There was nothing Box could do.
Box knew his big head was
going to hang from the wall
of that man's lair
for the rest of time,
while the man apologized to
Box and all his relatives
for taking his life
and so forth.
That's how the old-time
hunters did it.
They put to the big sleep and
thank your relatives afterwards
by praying and so forth, so
your souls can live together
for the rest of time, while
he uses your claws as plates
for his smoking sticks
and so forth.
There wasn't nothing Box could
do, so he said to his self,
"It is a good day to die," and
turned on the man and waited
to sleep, but this
man knew too much.
Instead of throwing his
spear, when Box turned on him,
the man spoke to
Box in thoughtspeak
and you know what he said?
He said this, "I know it
ain't your 24th hour."
Well, that threw old Box.
I don't know what
threw old Box more,
man talking in thoughtspeak,
which is how animals speak,
or man speaking about
the 24th hour.
Both had never happened to Box
before, but man spouting off
about that 24th hour
put the whole thing
in a different light.
See, a lion won't sleep
but one hour a day.
The other 23 hours we mostly
sleep or look for fun or sex.
That's our game.
Lions is higher orders which
is all animals call our self.
It's mostly a pleasure trip
being a higher order, except one
or two rules you
got to stick to.
Box old fashion soul that
he was, was just floored
by that whole business.
He just didn't know what to do.
First here a man throw
thoughtspeak around like that,
then him going on
about the 24th hour.
Box got chickenhearted,
so he said, "Excuse me?"
"You heard me," the man
said in clear thoughtspeak,
"I know this ain't
your 24th hour.
You know how I know?
I've been tracking you, Box.
You're still in your 23 hours
of wandering around, sleeping,
looking for water and
fun and girls, all that,
so I won't kill you, for I
don't want your head now.
I want your head in the 24th
hour when you're hunting,
for I am a great chief
myself, and I'm looking
for something mighty like me.
So, I'm going to let you live.
I'm even going to suggest
a few things for you to do
in your three 23 hours, Box,
for I have traveled many places
and I know as many things,
and I can help you."
Then he padded Box on the
shoulder and turned him away.
That's when Box jumped him.
He knocked the man down, grabbed
the man's spear with his mouth
and stuck tooth in
down into the earth,
so the stick stood
up like a pole.
Then he snatched him up in
his mouth and whipped the man
across the stick back and
forth, beating the man
with his own stick, beating
the stick with the man,
and when he was done, he threw
him down and tore him up,
ripped him up, ran a paw
across the man's face
and killed him dead, then he
ate him or a good part of him
and slept a good two
days without waking up.
Many a day thought about Box
while sitting in this cage,
pacing back and forth
night and day, year in
and year out, thinking about it.
That hunter did no
harm to Old Box.
The man had him cold
and didn't kill him.
He even offered to
school Box on how
to live good in his free time.
Still, Old Box killed him.
You know why?
He was insulted, see.
If man had walked off and said
nothing, Box would've walked
on into the jungle and
gone about his business,
but man had to turn around
and tell a higher order,
a grown lion, what
was in his head.
Box didn't want that man to
find him and tell him who he was
and what all his plans was and
what Box was supposed to do
with his free 23 hours and how
man knew everything Box was
supposed to do in
his free 23 hours.
That was Box's 23 hours
to do with as Box pleased,
and just as long as
man wasn't fooling
around that magic 24th hour,
that one hour when nothing
in the world is safe from a lion
who's got to eat, then, well,
he was all right,
but he threw himself
in Box's business
them other 23 hours,
telling Box what he
could do with his time
and how he's supposed to
be sleeping and so forth.
He was counting Box's 24th
hour like it was his own.
Well, Box didn't like that.
He figured if the man was so
big in his breaches to count
up his 24th hour, he
might want to tell him how
to count his 23 hours
and tell him what to do
with his 22nd hour, and
the 21st, and so forth.
So, Box cleaned him up, beat him
with his own stick, and sent him
to the big nap, because he knew
it wouldn't be long before the
man told him what to do
with his one eating hour
and every other single hour.
I asked Box later, "What
did man sound like?"
for I had never spoken to man.
"You can't handle it."
he said. "What do
he taste like?"
I asked, for I had never
tasted man neither.
He said, "Tastes like chicken."
So, that's the story
called Mr. P and the Wind.
[ Applause ]
I'll just quickly summarize
the other stories for you
without reading them, unless you
want to hear some more reading.
I'm not -- some audiences want
reading, some don't, you know.
"The Underground
Railroad Box Car Set" is
about a toy collector,
and it's about a guy
who collects antique toys.
He's a Jewish guy from New
York, and he's the most famous
and most well-known, most well
regarded toy collector ever.
Like anyone who has toys,
who wants to sell their toys,
Softies, Christie's, they're
all scared of this guy.
Leo Bankskoff is the
best at what he does.
He's made a pretty good
living selling toys
and then he discovers that
there's a toy he finds
by accident, like the
Mona Lisa of toys,
and it's called the Underground
Railroad Box Car Set.
It's a box car set that's
related to General Lee
and it's a story of underground
slavery and all this.
But, it's the most valuable toy
train in the world, and he finds
out that it still exists and the
guy who owns it is a preacher
from a little storefront
church in Queens.
And, so Leo Bankskoff,
this great toy collector,
walks to the guy's house.
He's got 90,000 dollars
in cash ready to drop it
on this poor preacher and
his Amazon wife and his kid.
They live right at
Kennedy Airport.
Planes are flying, like, planes
are turning in his yard, okay?
And, he offers this guy
oodles of money for this toy,
and the guy, blows his mind,
says, "I don't want any money.
Take it." And, what, you know,
"Just take it, take the toy."
First, he has to find the guy,
because he can't find, you know,
he's got prayer meeting here.
He's doing the, you know,
willing workers here,
on Thursday preaching here,
he's in Newark on these --
and he's spreading
the Lord's Word,
spreading the Lord Jesus -- so,
he finally convinces the guy
to sell the toy, and after he
convinces him to sell the toy,
and now Leo can retire
forever, but he can't take it.
Why is this, you know, what this
is about, because the guy says,
"I'll let you sell it, but you
can't tell my wife or my son."
And, he agrees, and then
he, just by accident,
he finds out why,
and so you have
to read the story
to figure that out.
[ Laughter ]
"The Five-Carat Soul Bottom
Bone Band" is a story of a band
of boys in a small town in
Pennsylvania called Uniontown.
Uniontown is a little
town in Pennsylvania.
For those of you who
don't know Pennsylvania,
it's in Western Pennsylvania
close to Morgantown
and Pittsburgh, and
my brother-in-law,
who is a gastroenterologist, it
took me a long time to know how
to say that, but that's when you
go get your enema and all that.
Whatever that is, he is the
guy, and he's very successful.
He went to Howard.
You know, he comes from a little
-- he always say, you know,
"I came from this little
country town and, you know,
it's just two blocks long.
Me and Vivian Stringer,
the basketball coach."
And, so he used to talk about
it all the time and how they go
to Uniontown and how
blacks and whites lived
in this town all together.
Is that the ten-minute sign?
It was just -- well, anyway,
so I decided to create a story
in this town, because I like
working-class people whatever
that amorphous term means.
And, so this is about the kids
in that Five-Carat
Soul Bottom Bone Band.
The first one is about a kid
named Buck Boy who got shot,
who was shot and killed
robbing a Korean grocery store.
The second one is "Ray
Ray's Picture Box" which is
about a little boy
who was mentally,
I don't know what you say,
mentally challenged who --
the kids convince to get a box
of his father's pornographic
pictures.
And, they start selling
around the neighborhood,
and they really get in a lot
of trouble because of it.
The next one is about Blub,
a kid named Blub, who gets --
he gets himself tied up in a --
accidentally, gets tied
up in a horrible murder.
And, "Goat" is about a little
boy who is the fastest kid
in this fictitious
neighborhood called the Bottom
in this town of Edenborough.
And, so that's the Five-Carats
Soul Bottom Bone Band stories,
and then "The Moaning Bench"
is about five people who are
at the gates of hell,
and they're all
from all different
walks of life,
and the last of them is a boxer.
And, you know, they're
dealing with the devil,
and the devil is just ruthless,
and he's just talking, you know,
he's just cracking
jokes on them, you know,
makes fun of them, you
know, your teeth bad
and you have white cheese on
you, sucker and what, you know.
And, he has to decide
whether they go to hell or not
and when he gets
to the fifth guy,
and he yanks him
right out of life.
He just yanks wherever
they are, he pulls them
out like a little guy
got hit by a truck.
So, they're just yanked out of
where they are on
the Moaning Bench.
In the Baptist church, for those
of you who go to Baptist church,
they have -- nowadays,
they pull out a chair,
but in the old days they
would bring a moaning bench,
and when you accepted Jesus
Christ you sat, you know,
when someone would -- you know,
after the minister
delivers the sermon.
Then they pass around the tray
and that's when those of us
who played in church would --
you better play something
pretty.
And, when the music was playing,
they'd say does anybody want
to come, you know, is there one
and whoever came up would sit
on the moaning bench, and then
the elders and the deacons
and the deaconess and
the, well, you know,
the willing workers
would pray over them.
And, so this is called
the Moaning Bench
and these people are
sitting on this bench,
when the devil is deciding
whether or not they should go
through the door or up to,
you know, with the other guy
who is a person who thinks
he knows what he's doing.
So, when he gets to
the to the last guy,
he had yanked this boxer up,
who had gotten knocked down,
knocked unconscious,
and so the boxer stands
up and says, "What?"
And, then they have
this back and forth,
and so the boxer
tricks the devil
into boxing for their lives.
So, this is all about this boxer
who tricks the devil into boxing
for his life and the lives
of the other four people.
"The Christmas Dance" is based
on a true story of a judge
in New York that I used to know
and a Puerto Rican man
that was his friend.
They were veterans of
WWII in the 92 Division.
The man's name was
Florentino Lopez.
He was a Puerto Rican,
and the judge's name was
Florentino Lopez.
Those of you who saw "Miracle
at St. Anna" will remember,
the three of you who saw
it, that the protagonist,
the one who survives at the
end, is a black Puerto Rican
from New York, and
this is closer
to what really happened
to Florentino Lopez.
Florentino Lopez and Skiz Watson
were involved in this fight
in the town of Sommocolonia,
Italy in which an American --
a group of black
soldiers were surrounded.
During the Battle of the Bulge,
that wasn't the only place
where the Germans
attacked the Americans.
They also, they had a
gigantic push in Italy as well,
and of course no one knows about
that, because it's, you know,
black history -- nothing in this
world happens unless white folks
says it does.
So, but this battle in the town
of Sommocolonia was something
that Italians never forgot.
And, there was a soldier who
was involved in that battle
who had to, who was, he
acted extremely heroically,
and he later on got
the Medal of Honor
from President Bill Clinton,
but the ones around him did not,
and so this is based on that.
And, basically, what the
story is, is why these guys go
to this Christmas dance.
Every year, these two guys,
this judge, who is a lame
and this old Puerto Rican,
who have nothing in common,
every year they go to
this Christmas dance,
and this is revealed
to a doctoral student
from Columbia University
who is trying to figure
out what this dance
is all about.
And, the other two stories
are "The Fishman Angel" is
about a slave who meets an angel
who tells her that one day,
he tells this woman, "One
day you will be free,
free and free indeed."
The language I used
I can't remember,
and that gets communicated
vis a vis the story
to Abraham Lincoln, and he
ends up dropping those terms
into his -- dropping
the exact phrase into --
was it Gettysburg Address?
I can't remember.
You know, what's [inaudible]
the Emancipation Proclamation.
Somebody here went to
college, thank you very much.
Thank you very much, and
then the other is one
of my favorites.
It's called "Little
Abe", I think.
It's about a little mixed
race boy who believes
that Abe Lincoln is his father,
and it's called "Father Abe",
and he's discovered
by some black soldiers
from the Union army who are
in Richmond right
after Richmond fell.
And, it's just one
of my favorites,
because they don't know
what to do with this kid.
He runs away and they find him,
and they don't know what to do
with him, and they
don't know what to do,
because they're supposed
to be free.
And, this kid starts asking
questions about freedom,
and it's very, very,
very interesting,
and it's very pertinent to some
of the language that's
used now today.
I don't really write books.
I mean, you know, they put me in
the race and politics category,
but really, I belong
in the human category.
I mean, you know, race and
politics will always be there.
They're part of our lives and
they're part of what we have
to negotiate, but the fact of
the matter is all my books deal
with the commonality of
the human experience.
You know, one of my --
I mean, I've had many --
I've done a lot, you know,
unfortunately, but I remember
when I did one of these events,
and I don't do this that much.
I don't go out and talk anymore.
I just finished the novel, so
I did, you know, I mean, I'm,
like, into, like, the fourth
draft or something and --
but, even if I -- I just don't
like to talk about this anymore.
I think you should do it.
You do, you don't talk, you
do, and, you know, for me,
what I do is I run a
little program at my church.
I have 25 kids that
we train, you know,
to play piano and
drums and bass.
We train them, like, real,
like they train us, you know,
I'm training to get into
the Open Conservatory.
I mean, they won't.
Maybe one might, but
it doesn't matter.
If they get into City College
of New York, that's I mean,
because the discipline of
music teaches you everything.
It teaches you everything
you want to know
about being a writer,
because writing is the act
of continually failing
at something.
There's always going to be
someone who writes better,
who's faster, who's
clear, whose language is,
and there's always somebody
who's going to be smarter,
slimmer, blonder, heavier,
blacker or whiter than you,
but you can't be
you more than you.
No one could be you
more than you.
And, so, you know, all this talk
about, you know, all this talk
about this -- I remember
when I did an event one time
with Kurt Vonnegut, and this
lady raised her hand and said,
"Mr. Vonnegut, you writers
you've got the [inaudible]."
And, Kurt said, he said, "Miss,
we don't have the power
you think we have.
It begins with you,
not with us."
And, I always remembered that,
because I feel that when you --
our job, as writers, is
to illuminate and try
to make people see that
we are all the same,
but if they don't
want to see it,
it doesn't mean we
stop doing what we --
it should make us do it more.
We live in a time now when
we all have the same wall
to push against.
I mean, it used to be just black
people had the wall, because we,
you know, black New Yorkers
knew who Number 45 was.
We were very familiar with
him, and now everyone knows.
Okay, well, okay, it
doesn't matter what you knew
or what you did not know.
It just matters what you do
now in your own little world.
You know, when I was
writing the Color of Water,
after I finished writing it --
well, during the
time I was writing,
I was in Little Jimmy
Scott's band.
Jimmy Scott is a singer.
He's famous because he sounds
like a girl, like, you know,
he sounds like Nancy Wilson.
He never had a -- like his
thyroid never developed,
so he sounds like a girl.
Well, he sounded like a
girl, when he was alive, and,
you know something, we were
playing in Philly one time.
I was in Jimmy's band, and
so, you know, we're playing,
and my brother Richie came,
and my brother Richie was like,
he was like the jazzman
of the family, you know?
Culture and Sonny Rowlands.
So, after the set was over,
I went to Richie and said,
"Richie, what do you think, man?
What do you think of
the band, Richie?"
"You guys sound all right."
he said, "And, that
girl singing, she was--
" And, I said, "No, no.
man. Jimmy is not a girl."
He said, "No, no, man.
That is a girl.
She's little.
She got short hair.
She's an Indian.
That's a girl."
So, I said no.
He said, "Well, have you ever
seen him go to the bathroom?"
And, I, you know, it
never occurred to me,
and I said, "Well, no."
But, we were leaving,
went to Boston the --
that night we left to go to
Boston and we were in a van,
you know, those vans
where you can --
there's, like, sit eight people,
and Jimmy was in the front seat.
He said, "Pull over, baby.
I got to go to the
bathroom, baby."
So, the guy, the driver,
pulled over and went to one
of those rest stops, you
know those rest stops
where they hand you the key
on a wooden block like this,
and you know you don't want to
touch that wooden, you know,
who had, you know,
they hand it to you.
So, I say, "I got to the
bathroom too, Jimmy."
So, I went out, went
around to the side,
and he went to the bathroom
and he closed the door on me,
slammed it in my face.
So, I said, "Maybe it's
something to that."
Then when we were coming
back from Boston and we were
on a turnpike somewhere
and we went to one
of those bathrooms
where it was open.
And, then I just -- just out
of curiosity, and I looked
and I realized, well, his
thyroid hadn't developed,
everything else was
very much in place.
And ,I don't really know how I
got into telling you that story
but -- I know, I know.
I was in Jimmy Scott's band
and we were flying to Montreal
to open for Rosemary
Clooney who was a jazz singer
who was very talented.
You know, she sang with Duke
and all these great singers.
So, we -- and what
happened was we were late,
because the plane couldn't land,
and while we were flying, like,
I wasn't telling anybody in
the band I was writing the book
about my Jewish mother.
I didn't say anything
because this is just --
you don't bring your, you know,
you're playing in a group,
you're getting paid, you don't
bring your business to your job.
So, I never -- but
I was, you know,
I was learning all
this history especially
about anti-Semitism
in the South.
It was just disturbing,
you know,
and there was a little
Hasidic Jewish boy sitting
across the aisle from me, and
when the plane was circling,
they decided to feed us, and
they tried to give some --
I said, Well, don't
give him any.
He's not going to eat.
Just give him, you know,
give him some water,"
and so they gave him a glass
of water, because, you know,
he had the little pious
little braids and the yamaka
so they gave him the water,
and the kid took the water,
and I was grinning at the kid.
He did one of these, look.
[ Laughter ]
You know, he was smart.
His mother taught him don't
talk to strangers, you know,
which is what my mother told
-- so, anyway, we got to --
one of the guys in the band made
a crack about the kid, you know,
while we were flying, and we got
into an argument, me and him.
It was bad.
You know, when you're
traveling with somebody,
you're sick of them anyway,
and so the bass player
who was the straw boss
of the band was sitting
right next to me.
He's the guy who hires
everybody in the band.
His name was Hill Green
[assumed spelling],
and Hill didn't say a word.
He just looked grim, and
so we got to the event.
We were supposed to change
into tuxes, but we were so late
that we just did the soundcheck
in our street clothes.
We were just -- and
people were coming in
and we were doing a soundcheck,
and Hill was back there leaning,
he was playing his bass.
He was behind me.
I was in front, you know, I
was playing tenor in the front,
and Hill leaned over to me and
said, "You know what, James?"
he said, "That joke, that
wasn't funny to me neither."
And, he went back and he kept
warming up, and I'm saying
that to tell you that it's easy
to talk, but when you live it,
you inch the world for
just that much more,
and that's really
why we read books.
We read books to edge the evil
out of our lives just a
little bit, every day,
just a little at a time.
I'm not asking you to
sacrifice your mortgage,
but if you send ten dollars
to somebody who's running
for Congress who you believe
in, that's a good thing.
You don't have to beat
someone over the hip
because you don't agree
with them politically.
That's not the way.
You just move to the right,
move to the right way,
whatever way is right.
You know, hating on
people and one-upping
and putting comedy
shows and making fun
of people, it doesn't help.
It doesn't help.
People watch what you do.
The kids in my housing project
where I work, in the same church
that my mother started 65 years
ago, they don't know anything
about who the president is.
They don't care, but they
deal with despair and hatred
and disaster with so much
grace and so much kindness
and their parents, too, that it
just says, it just says to me,
you know, you just have
to keep living good.
You have to live better,
and so that's what gets me
out of bed in the morning.
Now, about my mother, my mother
died in 2010, January Ninth.
She died at home in bed.
My brother was in Puerto
Rico on his honeymoon,
and my mother waited for him
to get home and then she died.
I mean, at one point
she said, "Am I dying?"
and, you know, it was the most
difficult thing in the world
to say, "Yes," you know.
So, what I did was,
I said, "Well,
you know, Jesus is waiting.
He's coming.
He's waiting for you
on the other side."
You know, Jesus, you
know, she was a real --
the same religious fervor that
she had as a Jewish person,
she just transferred
it to Christianity.
So, she was very religious, and
she, you know, she just held God
in whatever form
he happened to be.
Now, I mean, you
might get up there,
you might find Rudy
Giuliani is running the show,
you never know, but whatever she
saw, she came to it peacefully.
And, it was an honor to be
raised by someone who was
so good and so kind
and so generous.
And, yes, of course, you know,
I'm a little more partial
to Jewish people than I might
be to, you know, I don't know,
Irish Catholics but not really.
You know, I mean, what
difference does it make.
Really, what difference
does it make?
So, in any case, that book
came out, and the only people
who read it in the
early days, really,
were young Jewish women
aged 20 to 80, honestly.
And, you haven't lived until
you've been to a coffee klatch
in [inaudible] New
Jersey or something.
"Let's check his teeth, wait a
minute, okay, it's all right."
It is okay, you know.
And, then, you know, gradually,
mothers came around to it
and then last but not least
here come the black readers.
They find, you know,
black women,
thank God that black
women read books.
Most of my friends have not,
my black men friends have
not read many of my books
and that's not because
they're bad.
It's just because they like
Dallas Cowboys, which I --
who cares, you know, really.
So, and then, and as a result
of that being successful I've
been kind of like the poster boy
for the mixed race
-- I mean, that's --
but see, I never really
accepted that role,
because I don't really care.
We're all mixed.
What difference does it make?
They call Barack Obama
the first black president.
No, he's just, he was
just a great president.
You know, I don't get
-- words, you know,
[applause] he was
a such a good man.
He was so smart.
He tried so hard.
You know, he was willing to
forgive, he never struck back.
He had such class and dignity.
If your daughter brought home
a son like that, you say,
"If you don't marry,
I'm going to kill you."
So, I mean, it's good that
people need to do that,
you know, but I don't think, I
think you politicize and gender,
and when you politicize
race and gender
and religion, you
make a mistake.
You have to humanize
it however you can,
and if people don't
accept it, so what.
It doesn't matter, and then "The
Good Lord Bird" really resulted
in -- I wanted to write a
book about Abraham Lincoln.
But, when I read Carl
Sandburg's books on him,
I was like forget it man,
because think Carl's --
so, I ended up writing
"Song Yet Sung",
which was about the underground
railroad, and then I came
to the John Brown
story while doing that,
and I went to Harpers Ferry.
I spent a lot of time on Harpers
Ferry, and I was fascinated
with John Brown, but I
wanted to do it in a way
that was really funny,
and so that's why Good
Lord Bird is a funny book.
I must've read about 25 books
when I wrote the Good Lord Bird,
and my next book, which is not
out yet but next year, is --
it's going to be about
-- it's funny as well.
It's about an old man, an old
quirky old man in the projects
who shoots like the most
ruthless drug dealer
in the project.
And, it's all about the projects
and the people who live there,
and it humanizes a part of that
world that most of us only see
from behind the wheel
of a locked car.
And, part of the reason why I
wrote that is that most of us,
when we write past
a housing project,
you know, we see "The Wire".
We see David Simon's version of
it, and David Simon is talented.
I worked with him.
He's a very talented person, and
I have no disrespect for him,
but there's another side
of poverty and hardship
and urban life that
most people don't see.
The people who work, the
people who, you know,
have second cousins who pull
out their teeth at Christmas
and go [cracking noise].
You know, there's a
whole world of humanity
that most people don't see,
and it's been my privilege
to see this in the
last six years
that I've been running
this program in Red Hook.
You know, I see people that I
knew grow up, some of them die,
and the dignity and the humor
and the joy of it and, you know,
it's just been a,
it's been wonderful.
Anyway, I got the
15-minute-queue
which means it's
time for questions.
So, you came a long way
to come and, you know,
if you want to ask a question,
just go right ahead, you know?
Just step to the mic and--
>> Can you hear me?
>> James McBride: Yes.
>> So, I just wanted
to share with you
that I had Five-Carat Soul from
the library and the audiobook,
but I didn't get to it.
I had to return it, so
I haven't read it yet,
but I read the James Brown
book in audio and before
that I read the Good
Lord Bird in audio.
And, I just want to know
what you think of the fact
that my full exposure
to your work has been
through audiobooks.
Are you in, are you -- I don't
know if I'm alone in that.
I just wonder if you're involved
with it, because there's got
to be other people like me.
We come to your books.
It's kind of a mediated format.
It's not -- you didn't
read, I don't think,
any of the audiobooks.
>> James McBride: No, I didn't.
I didn't read any of them.
I don't mind it.
I listen to audiobooks myself.
I'm reading -- right now, I'm
listening to Shriver Laurence,
Lionel Shriver's book
"Property", and I'm enjoying it.
So, I don't mind.
I mean, I don't want
to read my books.
I just feel like, you know,
I'm just not qualified.
I just can't do it, you know?
Once I finish a book, I never
have -- I had to reread this,
as I was coming here, to
figure out what happened.
I swear to god, I've given
readings, fiction readings --
I gave a reading one
time I told the lady --
the lady stood and she said,
"Why did you let her die?"
I was like, "She did not die."
And, the lady went like
this, "Right here, she died."
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
But, you have to remember
when you're writing fiction,
you know, fiction,
you don't really know,
you don't know what's
going to happen.
You just, you know,
it's in the air.
It's in the air and you ride
it, you know, and then it comes
to -- it just, it
settles where it settles
and then you get out, you leave.
You close the door, you thank
the people, you tip the waiters
and waitresses and you get out.
So, I just couldn't remember,
and that's really, you know,
that's really -- but in terms
of the actual audio
experience I don't mind it.
I mean, I would like
one day to do a book
where I would provide the
music and the sung lyric
and you sing it through.
I've tried it, you know, in the
case of one piece that exists.
I haven't published it
yet, because nobody,
no publisher is interested.
You know, they just
believe in music or book.
They don't -- there's no --
they don't believe that
you can combine them.
I know you can.
I mean, it's called opera, but
I don't really call it that.
I call it bopera, you know, it's
a way of combining good music
with good story, because
in any show that you see,
if the book doesn't work,
it doesn't matter how
good the music is.
So many good music songs come
from Broadway shows
that are gone.
The books carry the show.
I mean, I used to
do musical theater.
You know, I used to know,
I know Stephen Schwartz,
all those guys, you know,
when I was young and had hair,
you know, and wasn't afraid
to be broke, you know.
It was great, but anyway,
did I answer your question?
>> Yeah, so you have
no involvement?
Like, you haven't
listened to one of them
and gone this guy screwed
up the way he read my book
or I wish I had done it
or anything like that.
>> James McBride: Well,
I listened to this one,
Five-Carat Soul, and they
had different people reading.
I liked the guy who read
The Christmas Dance,
Dominik something.
He was my favorite.
I can't remember his name.
All of these actors
are very talented,
but it doesn't matter to me.
I'm not that picky about --
as long as the person is clear
and has, you know --
like I heard this actor reading
"The Old Man and the Sea",
Donald Sutherland read or --
and I just, I was fascinated,
because he talks with the
lisps, so everything --
and then I just thought
I'd focus on.
So, I couldn't listen to it,
because it just started
messing with my mind.
I was like, you know.
So, that's a book
I couldn't listen,
because I know his
work, and he's great.
He's a great actor, you know,
but then I just kept
thinking about that.
So--
[ Laughter ]
If Donald Sutherland has
any friends in the audience,
just tell him I,
honest to Jesus,
he's a good, he's a great actor.
I just -- it's not him.
I did listen to a "Moby
Dick" one on tape,
and that was wonderful man.
The last three chapters of
Moby Dick are the most exciting
chapters of fiction writing
that I personally can think of.
You have a question there?
>> I do. The Good Lord
Bird, which was magnificent,
I truly enjoyed it, but the
character, the little boy,
who's in the book, how
did you develop him
and where did you get
your idea for him,
because he was captivating?
>> James McBride: Well,
actually what I wanted
to do was I wanted
him to be a girl,
but I didn't feel confident
enough to write about a girl,
to write from a girl's
perspective.
And, so I said, "Well,
how can I do this?"
So, I just decided to make him
a boy and this would be good,
but then when I decided to
make him a boy, he just started
to really create himself.
Now, you should know that when
I read earlier from the Mr. P
and the Wind about the lion,
that's when the language
of The Good Lord Bird
began, because you'll notice
that in the language of Mr.
P and the Wind, "I'm a lion.
I live in a zoo.
But I was once a free
lion and never forgot it."
It looked to the similarity
of The Good Lord Bird.
I can't remember how it
begins, but I was once a slave
and something and --
but also the language
of the South was really crucial
to making that character to work
and that took a long
time to develop.
That started with that short
story, and for those of you
who are young writers, I
mean, not in age but young
in experience, oftentimes
your failures teach you things
that can help you later on,
if you're wise enough to hang
on to them and not throw
them in the garbage.
So, that boy just -- and
then I just read lots
of slave narratives,
and then after a while,
he came to life, you know?
Does that answer your question?
>> Well, it does, yeah.
He's just -- you just need
to know he's unforgettable.
You gave life
to an unforgettable
character, in my mind anyway.
>> James McBride: Well,
I mean the innocence
of children is a really
effective literary tool
if it's not overused, and
part of the reason why
that character works
for you, thank you,
is because he's an
old man talking
about the innocence
of his childhood.
So, he could talk like an old --
dirty old man but still recall
when he wasn't, not dirty
old man but just, you know.
>> I got it.
I got it.
>> James McBride: Not a
dirty old man, you know.
Yes, Sir?
>> Hi, I just wanted to tell
you, you are a treasure,
and I'm Jewish, and I love
jazz and am a teacher.
And, when I was listening
to the story about the lion,
I could see that story
being told to kids
and then really learning
something from.
The problem now is the language
and the limitations that are put
on you as a -- when
you're working with kids.
You can't, they can use the
language, but you can't,
and I -- the basic question is
how do you compare your jazz
love to your writing?
Where does that fall in?
>> James McBride:
Well, the short answer
to your question is I actually
wrote this wrote this story
for kids, but nobody
wanted it back then.
Shall I name them?
I shall not, but, you know.
What I use music for is I use
music to teach me structure,
because music requires
that you, you know,
at least jazz music
requires that you lay
out certain light points that
you have to hit as a soloist
and as an instrumentalist.
And, then I just, and then I'm
free within, you know, from one,
moving from one point to the
next, and that helps me --
it helps me create structure,
and once I know the structure
in my mind, then I can
go to it as a writer.
And, also story structure
comes in, an enormous amount
of it comes out of character.
I write character bios.
I do an enormous work
on my characters before I
write, before I do anything.
Now, with the lion
story I didn't,
because that was
just pure emotion.
It was based on my, just,
disgust with seeing these
beautiful creatures locked
in these cages, and that was
just, you know, sometimes,
every once in a while,
not a lot, but every once
in a while, the thing happens.
But, normally -- and for kids,
by the way, with my kids,
the kids who come to my program,
I don't allow cellphones,
and if I see a cellphone, I take
it and I put it in my pocket.
I mean, what we really
have to do with kids,
and I have enormous
-- first of all,
we don't pay teachers enough,
teachers and cops and firemen,
they just don't, you know,
it's just ridiculous.
I sense a schoolteacher
or two here.
I do it, I feel it.
No, but we don't pay them
enough and part of the reason
that that job is so difficult
is because kids can't focus,
and they can't focus,
because they're looking
at that cellphone all day.
You got to, you know, we
have to monitor the behavior.
Anyway, we have time
for one more --
did I answer your question?
All right, thank you.
One more question, and then
we only have two minutes
and then the next
group comes in.
Go ahead, yeah.
Is this -- I'm sorry.
Go ahead. I'll answer both
very quickly if you just--
>> Thank you.
I've been in a book
club for 23 years,
and of our first books we
ever read was, you know,
The Color of Water, and
whenever I get a chance,
I pick one of your books,
and next month we're
doing Five-Carat Soul.
So, my question is what should I
tell my gang what you personally
would like to share with
us about writing the book
and what you haven't
shared with other people?
[ Laughter ]
>> James McBride: Now, that's
a book club I want to go.
>> Yeah. We're having lunch
at the Stratford
Hall on October 13th.
>> James McBride:
No, that would be --
we've got to build that wall.
That's all there's to it.
We've got to build that wall
and keep them out and all right.
Well, I had a hard time figuring
out the order of the stories,
and I had a really hard time
putting together the Christmas
Dance, because that book,
that story is really,
really disjointed.
It's really structured in a way
that took an enormous
amount of work.
You can tell them that,
and it's all true.
>> Okay.
>> James McBride:
All right, last one.
>> Okay, so what's your
experience been creating
in different art forms?
So, I was trained as, I've been
trained as an opera singer,
and that's taken a lot of --
just a lot of effort and focus
on that field, but I want to
do so much more artistically.
>> James McBride: Okay,
that's a good question.
Well, I know exactly what
you're talking about.
The amount of discipline
required to hone
that great instrument that
you have, you have to start
to just translate, just push
that into something else
that gives you some
creative umph.
Most musicians like yourself
don't realize how well they
can write.
Musicians, opera singers,
classical players,
jazz player as well,
they're so faithful
to what the creator has
done that a lot of --
and training to recreate what
has been done so magnificently,
they shut off the valve
to their own creativity,
and there was a very interesting
article about Ethan Hawke today
in the Times, and I know Ethan.
Yeah, me and Ethan we
just kick it, you know?
We grooving and grooving.
No, he's making The Good
Lord Bird into a tv series.
It's funny, he came to the
church, and when he came
to the church -- because I
said, "I'm not going over.
I'm at the church down the
street from you, come on over."
He came to the church and
he walked in the door,
and one of the ladies
said, "Are you here
to fix the air conditioner?"
But, the reason why I
bring that up is that --
and he was cool about.
He was good, but the
reason I bring that up is
that you spend years training
this instrument of yours
to do this, you know, this
wonderful thing without knowing
that while you are
singing [inaudible]
or whatever it is you're saying
that you're tightening the valve
to your own creativity,
so that a mistake
in that is actually the
beginning of a melody here.
And, so you have to kind of
figure out where in that,
in your genre where
your strengths are.
Are they in the storytelling
side or on the music side?
Probably a bit of both.
So, if I were you I
would just take a --
if not take a writing class,
take a creative writing
situation for yourself
that forces you to study the
works of some of these great,
you know, some of these
great librettists,
so that you would say,
"Why does this work?"
And, then just read something
like, you know, read something
like -- like "Bird by
Bird" by Alice Monroe
and Richard Key's
book on screenwriting,
stuff that just gives you
technical things to think about.
The thing is that
you don't need --
you don't need talent,
you just need skill.
You have the talent, so
you have to find the skill,
and if you can sing opera, if
you can sing classical music,
you certainly can write a book.
And, on that note,
thank you very much.
Thanks for coming out.
[ Applause ]